Now in some applications you might have the need for many small scans
instead of 1 large scan.
We've said before that when you launch a kernel on a GPU,
you want to have lots of work to do in that kernel.
So it doesn't make a lot of sense to launch a scan kernel separately
on each one of these small scans.
Instead, we're going to pack these scans together as segments inside 1 big array
and then have a special scan operator that scans each of the segments independently.
Typically to indicate where segments begin in an array
we use a second array that has 1s for segment heads and 0s for non-segment heads.
Let's do an example.
So if you'll recall, exclusive sum scan on an array
simply takes the running sum of all elements that come before the current element.
So the sum of all elements before 8, for instance, is 28.
Now what's different about a segmented scan is that we have a normal array,
but what we do is we're marking with these large lines here boundaries between these segments.
So when we call a segmented exclusive sum scan on this array,
what it's going to do is take separate scans of each of these 3 segments.
So the result is the scan of 1, 2, the scan of 3, 4, 5, and the scan of 6, 7, 8.
And so the way that we're going to represent these segments is with segment heads
so that we have a second array the same length as the input array that marks where segments begin.
So a segment begins here with the number 1,
a segment begins with the number 3, and a segment begins with the number 6.
So to make sure we're on the same page,
we're going to take the same array we did last time
where we computed an exclusive segmented sum scan
and instead you're going to fill in the result of an inclusive segmented sum scan on this input array.
If you'll recall, an inclusive sum scan is going to be the sum of all elements
that came before in the segment as well as the current element.
So why don't you fill in these 8 boxes?